they both love each other very much and
care about each other but it doesn't
always mean that people are together is
olicity gone for good
et caught up with the Stars at arrows
100th episode celebration to get the
inside scoop on what's next for Oliver
and Felicity's romantic future I feel
like they still have like a really deep
connection and they just need to grow
apart and to be honest they are more
dynamic apart this season than they were
together last season so I feel like it's
a really good thing a while since I
dated anyone is this a thing though no
this is the thing this is this is a very
long funny story it's cool to have a new
love interest in her life I don't I feel
like it's a little soon but everybody
deals with her things in different ways
and I'd be like Felicity's just trying
to figure it out like we all are and
she's just trying man
she was really trying and she's trying
to be honest and get through it we're
good we have some arguments coming up
but I feel like we have a good dynamic
going and really respecting each other
is teammates you do need to grow a part
of sometimes where you can grow together
and he can join this Multan what do you
think about the fact that emily has a
new love interest this year um I am a
little upset I don't know like I was
definitely like an all the city shipper
I mean I think I still AM but I still
had hope for like some somehow Roy and
and Felicity but there was this whole
thing member isset II there was gonna be
a love triangle originally for the
second season
I just apparently we didn't have
chemistry can you believe it it was
gonna be a like a three-way love
triangle between Roy Oliver and Felicity
could sell like a couples comedy of the
two of us if we could get through a
scene without laughing like with zero
chemistry
you